today we get to take our amateur skills
and put them to the test
yeah i'm impressed ah
fail let's see if we learn enough
techniques
to pull off like a cool movie style shot
that's gonna be us i think maybe
here we are at the willow springs
international raceway with naoki and the
drift 101 team
because you know what we've been sitting
behind our computers for years and years
clicking on our mice poking at our
keyboards and watching other people do
crazy things like car chases and movies
and i've always wondered myself
how hard could that really be well david
aka that dude in blue has hooked us up
here with the drift 101 team
to take us outdoors onto a track and
give us some real life
lessons for some crazy driving
techniques let's see
if we learn enough techniques to pull
off like a cool
movie style shot at the end of the day
let's see if we can achieve a little bit
of that pizzazz that
real good drivers have my name is naoki
kobayashi i am the owner of drift 101.
for me the best way to define drifting
is the intentional
act of getting a car sideways through a
navigated course
sort of the same way parkour has become
the staple
of chase scenes in movies now drifting
has also been somewhat incorporated with
chasings with cars so we've been working
with a lot of stun people
teaching them and having them understand
what does it take to get a car
sideways not just for fun sake not just
burning up tires
but also to be accurate and precise on
movie set
where safety is of the importance so are
your cars custom machines like have you
gone through and like modified them at
all believe it or not
we haven't done too much per se the
motor is actually
factoring we don't want to give too much
sort of luxury
to drivers to where they over overly on
certain things
yeah we're focusing on the basic
fundamentals of just understanding the
car
i'm feeling quite confident we've done a
little bit of drifting
a little bit of drifting you know we
grew up in minnesota there's a lot of
snow there i know what it feels like to
like
you know counter steer and like lose
traction and we know how to use the
e-brake
we know how to drive manual cars so i
think today we get to take our amateur
skills and put them to the test
deep down inside i feel like i have what
it takes i'm sitting there i'm like
talking to stuntman on our channel like
every week and like
i gotta prove to myself that i can pull
off the moves we'll see i mean i don't
want to be too overconfident i guess
with all the experience you have i'm
sure we'll be
learning a ton of stuff here so um i
guess we'll just sort of do a quick demo
you'll get an idea of what we're
planning to teach
[Music]
i think maybe wait we're gonna drive the
cop cars yeah
oh no see the thing is the nissans have
like a lot of the guts taken out so
they're a little lighter
these cop cars look like they're kind of
chunky beasts nico okay
you're in a car it's easy to drift quote
unquote all right so what do you do
we gotta figure this out well i've never
done rear wheel drive drifting i've
always done e-brake drifting i've never
lost traction by flooring it before i
think i figured that i was watching
there's this stick in the middle it
looks like so this wheel controls the
front wheels
but the stick controls the drifting so
you push it the direction you want to
drift
do you know how refreshing it is like
teaching people car stuff who have a
clean slate
aside from just getting a car sideways
we're going to have you guys actually
get the car to a 90 degree stop just
like what you just saw here so
you guys ready yeah i'm so ready let's
do this
i just want you to go out to the two
cones out there
and see if you can countersteer your way
around the second cone so it's just a
simple j-turn
we're going to see if you guys can do a
controlled 90 stop as you saw in our
demo
build up some momentum handbrake and
then see if you can get it to controlled
stop
to the two cones it's a manual car right
yes sir what gear should i be in
first game okay no more questions
[Music]
alright nico you can do it
whoa okay okay not bad
he bought a little bit of understeer
when he initially went in but
i liked how we tried to add the counter
steer to prevent the car from just
simply over rotating so that was
actually a good start yeah i'm impressed
all right we'll see how this goes
i feel like with another futurist i can
get it i uh i definitely i hit the break
a little early
but there's no impressive that means a
lot though that's really boosting my
morale
all right i just received the best
compliment i could have ever gotten
have you done this before
you know some of the best advice i've
ever given is that when it comes to
things that go between you and the
ground
you should always go for quality that's
why today we'll be talking about vessy
shoes
the thing that's unique about investing
shoes is that they are fully waterproof
slush proof sandproof all kinds of proof
the material is a dual climate knit
meaning that in the summer when your
feet are hot it'll keep them cool and in
the winter your feet are cold it'll keep
them hot
i wear these shoes on one wheeling and
water and muddy terrain because they're
waterproof and easy to clean
fancy shoes are both easy to dress up
and dress down and they sell it quick so
head on over to bessie.com
corridor crew for 25 off each pair of
shoes
vestey.com corridor crew for 25 bucks
off each pair of shoes
alright see you later
that was lame that was lame
so that was pretty good for your first
time the only thing i noticed
is you were turning the steering wheel
before you got those rear wheels to lock
up
that'll adjust your end mark quite
significantly
with the steering wheel it's actually a
small steering input you want a
quarter turn of the wheel about 25 of
the wheel
sounds good here we go
ah
fail i failed looks like you didn't get
locked up
rough we just didn't pull it hard enough
ah i'm letting go too early
i think i'm starting to overthink this
whole thing subconsciously in your head
you almost want to think about
intentionally trying to spin out let's
see if we can find a balance between
your first run and your second run
okay sounds good
oh this oh he gets there right he's
going to get it
that one oh it's good that's actually
not bad good correction on the steering
wheel
was straight just straight never do a
full lift on the throttle okay
always give me about 20 to 30 percent
during the time that you're
in a counter steer trip okay okay i
think you got this
yeah much better that was perfect
i love how just slips out on you it's so
good i know he's gonna bring up
don't have time now yeah don't have time
now all right here we go
let's see if i can actually do it
all right let's see if my advice helps i
just told him to just be active with a
throttle
and uh we'll see if he stays active
[Music]
there you guys
hey hell yeah
i wonder how the uh parking lot is gonna
be at your place now yeah
there it is
that's really good for a first time i
gotta say
i mean i'm real sloppy it's like i'm
just holding on by like the seat of my
pants
i mean that was the best tip that naoki
just gave me was just keep the gas
at a minimum at like 20 the whole way
through and like that
made a huge difference it's like it's
not about going fast it's about being
graceful
it's about the dance i can see where all
the nuance and like
the precision comes in and like it's
hard to be precise because you know
you turn not by turning you turn by
slipping and it's
it's great though it's a really cool
feeling i hope we have what it takes to
do a cool scene at the end of this
yeah i got some 90 degree stops in i
used my like snow drifting like
knowledge and i got there pretty quick
but i was like really
it wasn't precise but by the end i got
that precision down a little bit more
as long as i understand the trusted
process you'll be surprised at how much
they'll actually learn in the day
how did we do actually you guys did
really well yeah i was actually
impressed
it makes me feel really good yeah i
thought your drifts were
pretty cool thanks man yeah your 90
degree stops are also really well done
thanks
thanks sam i've just learned some new
skills new filmmaking skills if you will
and we're going to attempt to put those
to work we're going to try to do a
little mini chase scene we're going to
keep it safe but we're going to try to
utilize
these cool moves we got all right we're
good all right cameras are set
sounds good and rolling and action
moving into pass
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
now that we've had a chance to sit in
the driver's seat it's definitely given
us a newfound
appreciation for what we see on screen
a lot of these tricks we're doing today
seem like they're
difficult and they they are but what's
good is that they're approachable
it's all about feeling those
fundamentals out and i think we've
managed to do that can we pull off these
tricks when stunts with the same degree
of accuracy as a pro
definitely not that requires a lot more
practice
but it feels very approachable not gonna
lie i feel like if i
did this every weekend for the next few
months i probably could get pretty dang
good
it's been amazing they're great keepers
come on down here links in the
description below and that dude blew on
youtube
thank you so much for making this all
happen all right
we also have a very special episode of
stuntman reaction called stunt drivers
react where david is joining us
to break down all the ins and outs of
cars and movies so you guys stay tuned
for that episode coming out subscribe if
you haven't
and uh yeah we'll see you in the next
one